tanz und gerade deshalb vielleicht
bleibt sie uns oft länger erhalten
nach 30 wirtschaft ist
das deutsche hygiene museum in dresden
setzt auf die freundschaft wo sonst
themen wie migration schönheit oder
reichtum verhandelt werden geht es jetzt
um die freude an den freunden
der kurator daniel thürer dellis
ergründet das universum dieser
besonderen verbindung er fragt nach
bedingungen und bedeutung von
freundschaft freundschaft ist man möchte
irgendwie miteinander sein aber warum
ist eigentlich gar nicht so leicht zu
sagen und gerade dieses dieses fehlen
des unmittelbar angeht waren zwecks da
blitzt sowas übermenschliches auf
nämlich ein jenseits von zwang und
ökonomie freundschaft ist die sehnsucht
nach einer unverbindlichen bindungen die
hält in dem sinne es gibt zwar keinen
grund das heißt ich kann jederzeit
wieder aufkündigen
aber wenn sie denn hält ist sie umso
wertvoller
die reproduktionen an den wänden
erzählen von echter nähe intensität bei
cola und vertrauen
ein gemälde von über maler picasso die
großen meister rücken die freundschaft
ins bild geben ihr ein antlitz vor dem
achtzehnten jahrhundert galt diese
bindung als das höchste gut
aus heutiger sicht ein drahtseilakt denn
die blicke und gesten gehören nicht
allein der freundschaft sondern auch der
liebe
die ausstellung zeigt wie dieser starken
verbindung das bürgerliche liebes ideal
entgegen gestellt wurde
leben in ehe und familie bildet das
fundament der gesellschaft
rückendeckung für den staat wenn die
menschen das ziel der existenz in der
liebe sehen dann fokussieren sich total
auf die privat beziehung und absorbieren
ihre energien auch darin das nennt man
dann halt freiheit oder suchen der
begriff der freundschaft mit der
freiheit ist ein anderer nämlich wir tun
uns zusammen weil wir irgendeine idee
haben die gar keine gesellschaftliche
sanktionierung hat aber wir würden das
gerne machen das kann halt nun mal sein
wir gehen zusammen surfen es kann aber
eben auch sein wir machen revolution
dieses potenzial der verbindung ohne
verpflichtung scheint verlockend für
unsere gesellschaft ersetzt der
kontinent freundschaft bald die familie
die kleinfamilie muss nicht der einzige
weg zum glück seien kinder kriegen geht
auch jenseits des konventionellen
lebensmodell und vor der alters
einsamkeit retten uns die freunde auch
online freundschaften sind das auch
beziehungen dass facebook projekte
amerikanischen künstlerin tanja
holländer widmet sich genau dieser frage
sie besuchte jeden ihrer 626 virtuellen
freunde zu hause
die fotografien zeigen menschen die ihr
nahe sein sollten es aber nicht sind ein
ringen um die freundschaft gibt es nicht
hier gilt licon bruder löschen die
technischen möglichkeiten können einem
immer mehr freunde theoretisch zur
verfügung stellen indem man sie aufgrund
seines profils abruft es kann aber auch
bedeuten dass man bei einer freundschaft
in der krise nicht mehr genügend energie
investiert sie zu retten und eine
gerettete freundschaft kann unter
umständen eine viel höhere intensität
dann irgendwann gewinn als die die nur
so kurzfristig und willkürlich für ein
paar wochen funktioniert wäre der beste
freund des menschen auch freiwillig mit
uns befreundet
und warum sind wir immer mit denen
befreundet die so sind wie wir das
zentrale bei der freundschaft wird hier
formuliert müssen freunde einen immer
unterstützen oder sollen freunde uns
infrage stellen freundschaft heißt einem
anderen sagen zu können ich finde ich
doof oder ich hab dich lieb aber es
heißt vor allem du bist so wie du bist
und das ist okay und wenn man das nicht
hat ist man ohne freunde und das ist
wirklich stimmt
einzig richtig schön einfach die
freundschaft und und wodurch